[Music]
we're back in st louis overboard chess
is back as well how does it feel for
everything to be coming back to normal
yeah phil it feels really good i also
had the same similar feeling that this
is the first time that i
come to play again and things feel uh
very close to
what they were
before the pandemic
and
and it's great i hope that we can
continue on this trend and that
this is uh
a good start of the chess season in san
luis oh i'm i'm just really happy to be
back playing over the board chess it's
been pretty much two and a half years of
playing online bullets bullet rapid and
starting to play over the board just
almost feels foreign to me you know
after playing all these woods games
online
yeah i'm really happy to be back in st
louis i mean i'm happy that things are
getting back more to normal you know we
don't have any mask requirements anymore
um yeah it just feels pretty normal and
i'm looking forward to playing yeah it's
going to be different right no masks
finally
just seeing each other seeing
expressions everybody has to come back
to poker face
because every like gesture is very
visible when you don't have the mask but
i look forward to it i think we are all
excited to to play this tournament this
format is like absolutely fabulous
obviously um it's much nicer to be in
person and especially to be playing in
such a prestigious tournament with all
the best players in the world well i'm
very excited you know first for quite
some time we're gonna have some audience
just
next to us watching the games
and
i think we're all ready to put up a show
yeah it's pretty exciting yeah it's been
a while since i played the tournament
and this is the second time i play in st
louis
and it seems like a really cool event so
i'm glad to be invited i am very happy
actually first time when i played here i
had to wear a mask so this time it's
going to be my first time without
wearing a mask and it's going to be
totally normal and i'm very excited
about that
yeah it's great i mean i was not playing
chess for a couple of years and even
after the us championship i didn't
really play for a while
until i played the spring classic
recently so it's nice to kind of play
two tournaments within
less than six months apart
so hopefully i'll be in you know a
little bit better of a groove going to
this tournament and uh yeah hopefully it
will show my play but mostly it's just
fun to be
be back on the board i'm thrilled to be
applying my first st louis event of 2022
obviously you know i can't remember the
last time i've played a tournament in
the u.s that wasn't in st louis i mean
this is clearly the place for uh for
american chess you know i've always
loved knockout tournaments you know
being playing able to play a really
strong elite knockout event with some of
the best players from all over the world
is really great oh it's awesome to be
playing again i haven't played this is
my first tournament of the year so i'm
really looking forward to it and it's
just kind of nice to have some normalcy
again i really hope i really hope it's
back to normal and we will continue
playing chess and playing without masks
and enjoying chess games and enjoying
like social chess life
like doing some chess camps which i'm
missing i usually teach in a lot of
chess camps so
i hope everything will come back
now okay we can see everyone's beautiful
faces again and
yeah i think
it's really nice sign i'm hoping that
things remain this way
and yeah tournaments are coming back so
it's just really nice
usgs is only getting stronger and
stronger i'm very excited because i'm
actually trying to focus on over the
board this year
so this is my first term and after this
two tournaments in granchester and then
norway so
i'm gonna be playing chess for two
months basically but it's a good start
yeah it feels pretty much back to normal
now
uh
i mean we played the us championship
last year so that was already i guess we
were starting to get in gear of
over-the-board tournaments coming back
and and this this is really nice to
to be back here again and uh playing it
feels sort of like a u.s championship
again but with such a unique format
that not not quite us championship